[Musik]
und mit dabei ist peter tschentscher der
erste bürgermeister von hamburg ich
grüße sie ganz herzlich
guten morgen guten morgen was erwarten
sie was soll das eigentlich mit diesem
lebens gipfel
wir müssen jetzt wirklich das
durcheinander einmal ordnen denn die
länder sind seit mitte dezember bereit
große mengen impfstoff einzusetzen so
wie es im oktober angekündigt worden ist
und seitdem gibt es woche für woche
probleme mit dem einen impfstoff mit dem
anderen
es werden liefermengen immer wieder
reduziert termine verschoben
und das ist etwas sehr sehr
enttäuschendes und viele menschen warten
dringend auf einen impftermin und
deswegen soll heute auf dem impfgipfel
klarheit geschaffen werden wir brauchen
zuverlässige angaben der hersteller wann
mit welchem impfstoff zu rechnen ist und
wir brauchen einen nationalen impfplan
denn es gibt für die nächsten monate ja
eine große aufgabe
der bund hat zugesagt dass bis september
alle menschen in deutschland eine
impfung erhalten sollen
und dann muss es langsamer losgehen ja
also das heißt die kritik die sie damit
verbinden geht in richtung industrie
also der hersteller von dem stoff na ja
es geht darum dass wir klarheit brauchen
der bund hat die aufgabe übernommen die
dem stoff zu besorgen
und hier werden einfach immer
informationen weitergereicht von einem
zum anderen ohne weitere erläuterungen
ohne hinweis darauf hast wirklich jetzt
die nächsten wochen passiert und
natürlich gibt es probleme die
impfstoffproduktion ist nichts was man
von heute auf morgen mal herbeiführt
aber es muss keine geben und es muss
verlässlichkeit in der planung geben
es kann nicht sein dass wir mal eben am
wochenende erfahren dass ein weiterer
hersteller erklärt hat dass seine
bisherigen zusagen nicht eingehalten
werden sowohl die hersteller wie auch
die bundesregierung sind hier in der
pflicht sich zusammenzusetzen wir als
länder sind bereit alles dazu
beizutragen was nötig ist damit die
impfstoffproduktion zuverlässig wird und
dass sie auch erhöht wird
doch sicherlich einen kurzen draht also
nicht wie unser eins der sich dann vor
die tagesschau oder vor die heute
-nachrichten hockt und geschaut was dann
informationen kommt sie können doch da
mal eben anrufen auch bei den
parteifreunden
ja sie wissen ja dass wir aus in einem
sehr engen austausch stehen nur die
antworten sind immer sehr unbefriedigend
und die nachricht letztlich lautet erst
gab es probleme bei brenntag jetzt gibt
es probleme bei moderner auch die
zusagen von astrazeneca da kursieren
jeden tag neue zahlen
und was die länder wirklich erwarten
dürfen was die menschen die auf impfung
warten wirklich erwarten dürfen ist dass
es einen plan gibt und wenn es
impfstoffe zu sagen gibt dann müssen
diese bestand haben
wir können nicht termine vergeben und
sie dann kurz vorher zurückziehen das
ist jetzt schon eine sehr große
enttäuschung und sehr viel verärgerung
in deutschland und deswegen kommt jetzt
darauf an einen verlässlichen klar zu
machen und auch alle optionen zu nutzen
um die impfstoffproduktion in
deutschland zu erhöhen
gut das könnte ja also diese
verlässliche plan könnte heute am ende
bei rauskommen das ist das eine
gehen sie denn auch mit ihrem
amtskollegen in berlin mit der die
bundesregierung also namentlich auch die
bundeskanzlerin und dem
bundesgesundheitsminister angegriffen
hat wegen des jedoch schlecht management
ich will jetzt keine vorwürfe verteilen
weil wir ja letztlich in einer lage sind
in der wir lösungen finden müssen
aber natürlich ist es so dass immer neue
erwartung geweckt werden
die ansage dass bis september in
deutschland alle eine impfung erhalten
sollen bedeutet ja dass wir jetzt
beginnen müssen
es kann nicht sein dass wir im juli
plötzlich 100 millionen impfstoffdosen
vor die tür gestellt bekommen und dann
innerhalb kürzester zeit diesen auftrag
abarbeiten sondern es muss schon hand in
hand gehen und deswegen ist es eine sehr
wichtige forderung gewesen sind
impfgipfel abzuhalten
denn wenn hersteller wenn
bundesregierung und länder jetzt
gemeinsam diesen plan angehen dann bin
ich zuversichtlich dass wir auch
vorankommen ja und sind sie auch dafür
eventuell andere impfstoffe einzukaufen
ich sage mal russischer oder
chinesischer ich bin dafür dass wir alle
optionen nutzen die es gibt
natürlich muss man bei impfstoffen sehr
sorgfältig und vorsichtig sein
sie wissen dass die
europäische zulassungsbehörde jetzt nach
eingehender prüfung drei impfstoffe
zugelassen hat da kommt es wirklich auf
die daten an denn eins ist klar wir
dürfen das vertrauen in die impfstoffe
die es in deutschland gibt wer jetzt
nicht dadurch infrage stellen dass wir
fahrlässig werden in diesen fragen
es gibt im stoff produktionen in
deutschland es gibt so einen impfstoff
der in deutschland entwickelt wurde der
hier hergestellt wurde
und da muss es möglich sein mit lizenzen
mit allem was es an technologischen
möglichkeiten in deutschland gibt jetzt
auch die impfstoffproduktion zu erhöhen
wenn man zwangsmaßnahmen so wie es zum
beispiel der grünen-chef tarek fordert
oder prämien für die lieferung für
höhere zahlen
ich denke wir müssen jetzt einen plan
machen und dann rückwärts aus den
erwartungen die wir geweckt haben und
die wir erfüllen müssen überlegen wie
wir vorankommen
und ich sage noch einmal wir müssen alle
optionen nutzen es kann nicht sein dass
wir überall auf der welt sehen wie die
impfungen vorangehen und bei uns wird
erklärt dass die impfstoffe rationen
gekürzt werden das ist nicht fair und es
entspricht nicht den großen erwartungen
die wir in diese impfstoffversorgung
gesetzt habe wie die briten zb am
samstag knapp 600.000 impfungen
durchgeführt haben ist natürlich ein
traum für uns und für sie wahrscheinlich
auch in hamburg aber dass deswegen noch
mal wenn sie dann sagen am ende müssen
wir dann gucken wie wir dann vorgehen
werden sie auch für so ein eingriff des
staates in die wirtschaft oder eben auch
für solch einen bonus oder ein
prämiensystem
ich kann mir alles vorstellen wir sind
ja in einer historisch
ausserordentlichen situation
und weil es ja auf jeden tag an kommt
jeder tag zählt ein lockdown hat große
schäden für die wirtschaft für die
kultur für die bildung für die freiheit
der menschen und deswegen ist jeder tag
jetzt wirklich richtig wir haben
todesfälle die vermeidbar sind wenn wir
jetzt weiter
nicht vorankommen mit diesen impfungen
und deswegen glaube ich ist in einer
solchen historischen ausnahmesituationen
auch jede option zu nutzen wenn sie
vernünftig ist und wenn sie dazu führt
dass wir wirklich vorankommen
aber wir haben ja eine angespannte
situation da kommen wir auch von grunde
genommen zum ende dieses gesprächs es
gibt viel kritik in richtung
bundesregierung es gibt viel kritik in
richtung eu kommission da wird auch über
schwarzer peter gesprochen
wo stehen sie dabei sagen sie auch da
ist so viel versäumt worden dass so viel
schief gelaufen
er hat die verantwortung für das
versagen oder sagen sie wir müssen
irgendwie auf sicht fahren ja
selbstverständlich muss man immer mit
der realität zu recht kommen es ist
nicht möglich jetzt über nacht eine
solche verworrene lage komplett zu
bereinigen
aber es ist schon eindeutig so dass der
bund vor geraumer zeit zugesichert hat
dass er sich um die impfstoffe
versorgung in deutschland kümmert die
länder sind für die umsetzung der
impfung also für die inszenierung
verantwortlich für die für das
management der impfung vor ort und ich
sage noch einmal wir können in hamburg
jeden tag über 7000 menschen impfen
wir sind darauf eingestellt auch noch
mehr zu leisten wenn der impfstoff da
ist aber es hakt jetzt an der aufgabe
die der bund übernommen hat und es ist
einfach nicht verstehen welche verträge
mit wem geschlossen wurden warum es
nicht möglich ist ein hersteller der
eine lieferverpflichtung übernommen hat
er schon angekündigt hat dass er
impfstoff liefert das dann einfach
solche zusagen zurückgezogen und termine
nicht eingehalten werden
das ist nicht das was wir in hamburg als
ehrbarer kaufmann es tun verstehen
es muss möglich sein hier eine
verlässlichkeit herzustellen
denn ich möchte nicht dass wir in
hamburg den älteren menschen termine zu
sagen und dann kurz vorher termine
wieder absagen müssen weil in dieser
ganzen kette an zuständigkeiten
irgendjemand seine versprechen nicht
einhält dann wünschen wir ihnen und uns
allen klar hätten heute nach dem
impfgipfel dankeschön nach hamburg peter
tschentscher sehr gerne